it is a big night tonight for our vegas
golden knights they are back now on home
ice at t-mobile arena for game five
and they could wrap up the first round
of the stanley cup playoffs against the
minnesota wild if they can pull it off
hector mejia live now with how medieval
maniacs are getting ready
hector is probably gonna be packed
tonight
well there's a lot of excitement yeah
alex hey there and some people are
actually showing up to uh purchase
tickets out here
and we're just hours away from toshiba
plaza here turning into a sea of black
and gold
inside t-mobile arena will have the
largest crowd of the year so far
after a capacity bump with more than
eleven
thousand fans expected inside the
fortress for game
five tonight the golden knights are back
in town today after they shut out the
minnesota wild saturday night 4-0
the knights can eliminate the wild if
they win tonight and vegas would advance
to the second round
of the stanley cup playoffs and if they
pull it off which we are rooting for
the knights would clinch a playoff
series at home for the first time ever
and for fans that's just building up the
excitement
this is the one to win and we don't want
to go back to minnesota
and we want to win this one and get it
over and done with i should say go wild
but i am going to say
go thanks i see the support of the fans
here i live in the state of hockey and
they have supported pretty good
but what i see in this city and the
support of people who are getting behind
the team
they deserve it
[Music]
with tonight's increased attendance
everyone is encouraged to arrive
early masks are still mandatory for all
fans over the age of two
that's under the nhl protocols and also
banks are not allowed and guests must
complete a
health questionnaire if needed that's if
needed the next game in the series would
be on one stay in minnesota and the puck
inside drops at 7 30 tonight but as
we've seen before you can bet we'll see
a lot of people here arriving early to
get the party started early
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you